[Music]
without the environment we are
non-existent
imagine walking through your normal day
life there's no way you can't interact
with the environment from the soil
underneath your feet to the air you
breathe to the sounds you hear
nature is a very very huge part of our
existence and we we shouldn't live in
this harmony with nature we should
understand that nature needs to be
preserved so that we can be preserved as
humans
a change maker boot camp in lagos
nigeria
twenty-year-old environmental activist
oluwashi mojo founded an ngo for
training the next generation of movies
and shakers
her students here explore ways to make
saving the environment creative and fun
[Applause]
such as separating waste in pairs with
their legs tied to one another
at the end of the workshop the best
project is decided on
the ngo you recycle supports the winning
idea
muijo's ngo has reached over 6 000 young
people in 11 african countries
i've learned new ways to upcycle recycle
how to go about it and how to be a
leader amongst my peers
i want to continue actually educating my
peers and people younger than me about
the impact they have on the environment
the good impacts and then the bad
impacts that they can also have on the
environment i also want to teach them
how to be leaders and be change makers
amongst their peers and other people
around them
[Music]
someone described the climate crisis as
for instance a young child is
is standing in front of a bus that's
coming straight ahead of him just smash
her in a bit of an eye
and then nobody's really doing anything
about it
students from the bright achievers
school have spent several days
collecting and cleaning plastic bottles
with a touch of paint they transformed
into street decorations for their
neighborhood
when you look at the other side of the
school
you see that we have a dead deer
which contains a lot of plastic bottles
and we see that we can make use of these
plastic bottles
and what we now come together as a team
that what can we use it for
last year the young people collected
over twelve thousand bottles as part of
similar projects
they are doing what they call upcycling
upcycling is a process of
converting waste into something of value
and this process is not just it's not
it's not like recycling because we said
we have to break it down to raw material
and use the raw materials to create
something but upcycling you add
in that stuff to create something like
probably an artwork a monument or
something that basically is very
aesthetically pleasing
the sprawling city of lagos has a
special waste management authority
holowashe moijo is hoping to get support
from the department which has just
acquired 100 new garbage trucks
the local government is also investing
money in local recycling incentive
programs
currently hundreds of recycling
containers are still waiting to be
installed around lagos
on a washer wants to ask the waste
management director why the city is
still choking in garbage
15 years ago these plastics they don't
they never existed
a lot of us were using glass bottle
tools
where you drink and then you return your
bottle back to
the bottling company to refill but with
the population challenge and the growth
it is necessary for us to find the
easier and quicker way to
to get all these all their products
worse
so if there is a way
we can prevent that usage
is always going to be better
than the recycling side of it
the young activist unexpectedly finds an
ally in the managing director
the two quickly agree to plan a joint
conference for high school and
university students
when is the next event again so the next
and the second day is march 18th every
year march 18th
right so we can plan
i think i'm happy let's do that let's do
it
and there's plenty of work to do before
that
[Music]
nigeria's constitution has so many laws
but it's just written most of them they
aren't put into practice
we need to make laws and
and effect loss implement laws
enforce those laws concerning preserving
the environment promised an issue like
climate change and glass flaring oil
spillage that is terribly impacting the
nigeria delta region there are laws that
are supposed to be protecting those
communities but
guaranteeing
followed because people are choosing
companies are choosing
profit over
profit of our planet profitable lives
when olowashi moijo isn't busy saving
the planet she studies law at the
university of lagos
here too her focus is environmental
protection
but sometimes even the most dedicated
climate hero needs a break spending time
with friends is a welcome reward after
all the hard work
i'm still
tired of sitting back and watching the
plan the planet deteriorates into a very
very horrible state right
we don't have much time and we need to
take action as soon as possible to
preserve what we love
and issues like climate change for
instance
is actually a threat to those things
no one is too young to make a difference
you've probably heard that before
and it's a fact don't ever look down on
yourself
don't ever look down your circumstances
your background your family like where
you came from you have so much potential
you